[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
Houston we have a problem
there was a crash
oh my God I told you yesterday said this
is not gonna go well you put your
presidential launch campaign whatever
the [__] that was yesterday from the
fascist Android in a skin suit Ron
DeSantis in the hands
of another fascist
Android and a skin suit Elon Musk
[__] didn't they know this
you could have just called Ron dude man
I
I'm not gonna run your campaign but [__]
man you could have called me
I've been telling you to announce this
for [__] weeks I said dude just get
out in front of a microphone I was
telling you how to do it
get go in front of a microphone anywhere
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
where just get in front of a [__]
microphone somewhere
and and
and [__] announce that you're gonna
run for president
and
and you're like oh yeah well I'm gonna
do it on Twitter spaces
best part about this whole thing is
people who are Elon since defending Elon
and defending Twitter are like oh the
mainstream media is just dunking on this
because Ron DeSantis broke the internet
no it you are such dummies it's radio
man it's radio the mainstream media
figured out radio almost a hundred years
ago you dumb [__] yes it's a
little different now because it's the
internet but man it's [__] radio it's
radio
we've had syndicated talk shows live in
this country that broadcast from one
space and and pump in thousands of radio
stations all around the country in
millions of radios Mill millions of
radios radios like the old style [__]
radios you put on a desk I'm not talking
about your goddamn smart phone
on an app like Twitter Twitter spaces
let me be clear is Radio
you [__] idiots
of course the mainstream media is gonna
dunk on Twitter because Elon Musk is
trying to act like he's competing with
him and last night we we got to see in
live and in action number one Rhonda
Santos is a [__] weirdo
Ron DeSantis is weird and he does not
connect with people
at all he's not even good at reading a
shitty speech
that's what I that's what I heard and
every time he every time someone asks
him a question he's like woken and we
want to make sure people have the right
genitalia
it's really weird stuff man it's weird
[__] it's weird stuff that every single
policy that you have starts with woke
and I want to know what people's
genitalia is it's [__] weird stuff
but anyways we'll lay that aside for
right now the fact the fact that Elon
Simpson Twitter sense think that spaces
is anything but Internet Radio you are a
dumb son of a [__] you are stupid
you're dumb you're just [__] ignorant
oh what but Tony there can be 10
speakers on the stage and they have
microphone buttons and they can talk and
thousands of people get that's what
radio is
what the f what the [__] do you think
have you ever listened to a radio I
don't know in the past 50 60 [__]
years the [__] out of here man this is
dumbest [__] I've ever heard of in my
life Ron DeSantis failed yesterday
failed crashed and burned professional
rake step I mean one of the biggest
digital rate steps of all time and he
made sure that the [__] dumbest son
of a [__] was running it Elon
come on why didn't he do it from his own
Twitter account why
why if you were gonna have such luck and
you were gonna break the internet Ron
DeSantis why didn't you do it from your
own Twitter account huh
why oh I know why I know why because
Rhonda santis thought it would be really
smart to get the Twitter and Elon Sims
on his side
that's what it was
it's what it was it's what it was it
ain't gonna work it ain't gonna work
here's why I tell you this
is because I was in a Twitter space that
wasn't the one that crashed I was in
Mario's Twitter space
and beforehand the DeSantis [__]
simps and the Trump sense were eating
each other alive do you know what
they're debating do you know do you know
what they fight over
Rhonda santis and Donald Trump I'm gonna
tell you so you don't have to go watch
this [__] it's it's [__] brutal it's
brutal to listen to them argue I mean
it's delicious it's delicious to listen
to the Rhonda Santa's supporter manga
supporters and the Trump manga
supporters fight each other on this do
you know what they fight over
they're they fight over for hours and
this hasn't been just this one time I
think this is the third time I've heard
them do this
in a Trump versus the Santa's type
little conversation that they have
they're fighting over
March April and May of 2020. I'm not
[__] you that's where they are
fighting over those three months the
first three months of coveted lockdowns
in this country that's what they're
fighting over I'm not kidding you and
they tell lies and they say oh you're a
liar no you're a liar no you're a liar
no DeSantis did this no he didn't he did
this no Trump did this no he did this
it's [__] beautiful it's [__]
beautiful and honestly if you want to
[__] with these people and I'm talking
about a a DeSantis supporter or Trump
supporter when they're out there
fighting each other right when they're
when you see them on social media and
you're like oh de Santa's this or drop
this [__] DeSantis Trump did this when
you see them fighting what I want you to
talk about is whatever side they're on
take the opposite side
of coven lockdowns I'm not kidding you
don't even have to tell the truth you
don't have to type in truth it doesn't
you don't you don't have you don't need
links you don't need articles you don't
need anything you just need to say if
they're in support of DeSantis say Trump
trump totally did a better job at coven
way better way better Rhonda Sanchez
[__] it up and the opposite is true if
they're in support of trump that's how
you [__] with them
that's how we draw this wedge I'm
telling you and I don't I don't know if
if the Democratic party knows this or
not but that's the wedge that will split
manga in half they can't get over it
they can't get over are you still are
you still concerned
at this point about covet I mean most of
my I would imagine that 85 are in the
low 90s percentile of my audience is
probably vaccinated
and they have boosters and they're like
well you know I don't want to get sick
but I got the [__] vaccine so I'm not
gonna have to worry about much right
you're some of you are probably wearing
masks when you go out not a lot of you
most of the world got vaccinated and is
moving on from coven
at least the risk that we had in March
April and May of 2020.
here's the reason why they're fighting
over this folks they can't fight over
the 2020 election because Rhonda Santa's
supporters can't say Trump lost they
can't say that [__]
if they start saying that [__] they're
really gonna fracture the other thing is
January 6th the January 6th Insurrection
they can't fight on that because they
all want it they all want to overturn
liberal democracy that's what they want
that's why they want Ron DeSantis or
that's why they want Donald Trump in the
first place so we have to draw the
wedges where their wedges are obvious
and they're making it obvious they're
making it obvious because they can't
stop fighting about it literally they
it's around and around and around and
around it goes about March April and May
in in 2020
based on covid lockdowns in Florida and
in the United States in general because
of trump but that's it that's that's
where the wedges are drawn I just think
it's kind of funny that they won't fight
over January 6. seeing today Stuart
Rhodes the founder of The Oath Keepers
is probably being sentenced as we speak
here's my prediction I posted it on
Twitter so you can see it I believe
Stuart Rhodes is gonna get a dirty 30.
the biggest news coming out of some of
this though is that Stewart Rhodes
defense team is blaming January 6 on
Trump they said January 6 would have
never happened there never would have
been an Insurrection no one would have
went to Washington without Trump
they're saying that out loud in court
today on public record in the sentencing
of The Oath Keepers founder Stuart
Rhodes
I believe he's going to get a dirty 30.
here's what a dirty 30 is it's 20 years
in prison 10 years probation that
prosecution is asking for 25 years uh
his guidelines are anywhere from 21 to
27 years I believe he's going to get 20
years
and 10 years probation something in that
Line's a dirty 30 or dirty 35 they call
it a dirty 30 because you served 30
years under the the Bop as you're
sentencing with the prison sentence and
the probation
so Stuart Rhodes I think he's in his 50s
I mean he may he may make it out in time
to not take a dirt nap but Stuart Rhodes
is going to spend the likely
a big portion of the remainder his life
in a federal prison somewhere
oh boy and that's what we're going to
hear here in just a few minutes
um probably I I don't know I uh Scott
McFarland was uh reporting on this from
the courtroom and he's live tweeting it
so I was trying to keep track of uh
exactly when the when the judge uh
decides what his sentence is so we'll
have that I just think it's I just think
it's kind of crazy
on a day like today where we get to Mock
and ridicule the meatball and oh my God
hi Texas to gave sanjays last night I'm
like man I've never been on the Trump
train but choo choo [__]
oh my God
I'm gonna show you a video that dude
posted on his fraud Social account holy
[__] [__] and Ben Shapiro Ben Shapiro
I'm gonna show you a tweet from Ben
Shapiro to you that [__] doesn't
even get it they don't get why Trump's
gonna win they don't understand it
I don't know why they're the one they're
the ones who created this this ecosystem
of these [__] brain dead fascists
that believe any lie that they're
supposed to be told I don't know why
they I don't know why they should keep
thinking like why is this happening why
can't the scientists well number one
DeSantis is a [__] weirdo and number
two
number two you create an entire
ecosystem around trumpism trumpism that
means he's still the king of American
fascism you [__] boneheads
what how how do you not know this how do
you not see why Rhonda santis Not only
was not going to win the nominational no
matter how well the launch went last
night on Twitter but seeing how a launch
went he is dead in the water Rhonda
santis is [__] finished before he got
started literally literally he was he
was done before he started speaking
that's what it was let me check in
um with the Stuart Rhodes trial real
quick while we're while we're talking
here because I think this is uh this is
very
um important uh on the sentencing it's
it's going to be a very very very very
important
um uh piece of news here on how many
years Stewart Rhodes actually gets um
and this is going to put pressure on
them let's see
[Music]
the judges speaking Stuart Rhodes oh
Stuart Rhodes
um seven minutes ago Scott McFarland uh
um reported Stuart Road Speaks now he
says I'm a political prisoner wonder
where he got that he got the idea to go
to the Capitol and overturn the
government Trump I think he got the idea
that he's a political prisoner from
Trump
um Rhodes blames a radical left they're
trying to shut down Trump and others
Rhodes is beginning his remarks with
talk of antifa this is not good for
Rhodes he may get he may get the 25-year
sentence plus 10 years he may get 35
full years
that he's going to be sentenced to with
this princess sentence and his probation
it is possible uh because I didn't see
him saying stupid [__] like this in
front of the judge
whoa whoa this judge is not probably
gonna have this kind of [__] these
[__] lies would be my guess and the
judge May slap 25 years on this
[__]
um Rhodes says we protect people outside
of trump rallies against antifa then
accuses antifa of a targeting unarmed
victims this tirade on on antifa is not
going to play well with the judge I
would imagine
um Scott McFarlane reports judges
sitting expressionless on the bench as
Rhodes unleashes these remarks about
antifa and targeting of trump supporters
he wrote These remarks down he appears
to be reading them off paper
that's probably not good I don't know
I'm just saying I'm just saying now the
reason why I want to talk about this at
the same time I want to talk about Trump
and DeSantis is because what Stuart
Rhodes is doing right now in front of a
judge who is going to sentence him to 35
[__] years is trumpism
it's the reason why it's the reason why
Trump will win Stewart Rhodes is gonna
go to prison for 20 25 30 years for
Donald Trump
because he believed his delusional
[__] lies and is standing in front of
a federal judge about to be sentenced to
the rest of his life in a federal prison
and he's still doing it
and you're standing around wondering why
Rhonda santis is gonna lose you're a
dumb [__]
it's a cult it's a cult it's a cult it's
a [__] cult
do you not know how Colt Works do you
not know how these [__] this [__] Works
do you know how long it takes
and how much how much effort it takes to
break the fever sometimes the fever
never breaks they drink the Kool-Aid
full on
and to some degree I really believe that
the Trump supporters are going to drink
the Kool-Aid and have drank the Kool-Aid
they drink the coveted Kool-Aid that's
what Rhonda santis and Donald Trump
supporters are fighting over when they
fight about March April and May of 2020.
that's what they continue to talk about
that's that's the [__] divisions that
they're trying to draw in their
narrative between the two and we should
help them oh my God should we help them
and I'm talking about helping them on
both sides
I mean you totally want to defend Trump
when someone's defending DeSantis and
when someone is defending Trump you
totally want to defend the Santas do you
see what I'm doing there you see how we
politicize it you see how we we use
these wedges
folks they're going to burn each other
down to the ground it's going to be
fantastic Donald Trump is going to ruin
absolutely 100 ruin Ron desantis's
political career
full stop
he's gonna ruin him
and last night was only the [__]
beginning and Ron DeSantis will be lucky
to make it out of the second maybe third
primary before he has to drop before his
corporate donors his big ass money
corporate donors tell him you're done
and Ronda santis will be done because
Ron DeSantis doesn't have the cult
Trump does Trump has the cult grift
and he'll continue it
that's why Trump continues to batter
Ron DeSantis about the big Mega
Republican donor class the establishment
is because Trump
doesn't want them he needs them he
doesn't want him he'll get him
eventually
Ron DeSantis is their only shot you
think Tim Scott's gonna beat Donald
Trump and [__] out of here Nikki Haley
you think Assa Hutchinson from Arkansas
you don't even know who the [__] that is
when I say that name some do who are
from Arkansas
know who Assa Hutchinson yeah I see it
as a
people point that out when I say it
that's why I say it
the comment you engage you're the best
goddamn audience in the world you are
truly and I'm telling you I'm telling
you the way that we Stoke this this
primary because this this election cycle
right now that we're in currently right
now today is not about Biden and Trump
it's not it won't be for a long time so
get that out of your mind stop thinking
about that wait stop thinking about that
how you can think about that right now
what you need to do
and your political discourse and your
engagement in your democracy is Drive
wedges
and the best wedges to drive right now
are right between Maga
right in the middle of them make them
make decisions about who they like
because think about this for a second if
we can draw wedges in Maga and we can
make pit them against each other in
whichever way we can and the most
efficient and quickest way there is with
this covid in March April and May of
2020 they [__] argue about this
vehemently
DeSantis is to blame trap is the flame
blah blah blah yeah as if anyone is
still thinking about March April and May
of 2020 and who shut down the government
and which governor and if it was the
governors if it was Trump who gives a
[__] it's over it was a shitty time it
was real it's really dumb to keep
rehashing [__] from the past but it
doesn't matter because that's the shift
that they want that's the fight they
want to have so let's get in there and
let's make them fight each other because
folks here's here's how it's gonna go
ultimately DeSantis is going to lose
he's going to lose he's already really
lost
he's just gonna pretend that he hasn't
lost yet because there's still a chance
that Trump gets indicted and the cult
doesn't follow him into the depths of
Hell which there's like a zero percent
chance of that
there's probably a better chance that
Grandpa Poopypants gets a Big Mac lodged
and he takes a dirt nap before he hits
the ground
hopefully but here's the thing here's
the thing is that Rhonda santis will not
win this primary but what Ron DeSantis
can do
is to make sure that we piss off as many
[__] fascists as we possibly can to
make Donald Trump think he's elected to
make them think Donald Trump is a
leftist that's the other thing because
of covet because Iran DeSantis welcome
organs Disney and blah blah blah yakity
smackity all that nonsense right he's
focused on genitalian he can't get his
mind off the lgbtq community and how he
can exterminate them
these people that are debating each
other in manga see DeSantis as more
right wing
than Trump trump is more left-wing think
about that for a second think about that
for a second in in the in the idea of
ideology
in terms of ideology
remember I keep telling you this over
and over and over again in our two-party
system ideology is everything and we can
use it to our advantage
and by our advantage I mean the
pro-democracy coalition
we can use ideology to advance our
Coalition we just have to politicize it
a little bit
we have to stoke it a little bit we have
to draw wedges in there here and there
and here and there
and if we make if we make Maga believe
that Rhonda santis is more fascist than
Donald Trump and Donald Trump is a lefty
that is going to be a huge wedge to draw
because Rhonda Santos will not win he
will not win but if we get enough people
enough people to believe that Donald
Trump is a leftist that Donald Trump is
a liberal that Donald Trump is a is a
libtard
imagine what could happen imagine what
could happen at The Ballot Box in
November of 2024. Imagine when the
Democrats go and find all of those Joe
Biden votes that they found in 2020.
Imagine when they add to those votes in
those areas as gen Z and the other the
other demographics explode
into the voting age
imagine what can happen if we politicize
their ideology and we force them
to suppress their own vote because they
can't vote for no leftist and I know
it's going to be on the margins and I
know it's going to be you know million
or two but hey folks
the bigger the margin the better in my
in my estimation I know we're going to
win at the top of the ticket in 2024 I'm
very confident in that our national
narrative is pushing and we're driving
and people don't like what Republicans
are doing they don't like fascism they
don't want you to ban books they don't
want you to ban Women's Health Care they
don't want you to tell [__] people
who look like a man going into the
women's restroom they don't want you in
their lives their love lives are
otherwise
they don't want it it's not the American
way it never has been it never will be
probably
they're unpopular
with the policies they do have with the
even the lack of policy that they have
so we can do this but we have to win
these down ballot races we have to get
people excited to go and vote all the
way down the ballot and we have to get
Democrats on these ballots
and I say Democrats not because I'm some
sort of shield for the Democratic party
because they're the party of democracy
just look at these states look at what
they're trying to accomplish in some of
these red states with these Republican
control legislators
yes yes Democrats are the pro-democracy
party it's in the [__] name but
they're the pro-democracy party they're
the only party that actually believes
rights freedoms and Liberty
at this point that's the choice you got
Nazis
are the guys you actually want to do
democracy who are serious about policy
who want to talk about you know children
starting school at three instead of five
who want to talk about you not going
broke because of a medical bill who want
to talk about making sure the college is
Affordable and it doesn't [__] chain
you to the ground with debt for the rest
of your life
they want to talk about making a decent
[__] wage and not having health care
cost you a gazillion dollars a year
making it affordable and accessible
making sure that your schools have the
right curriculum to set your child on a
course that they can be successful in
life that's what the [__] serious
Americans want to have a conversation
about
not Who's got what genitalia in the
bathroom
they don't give a [__] who's got the
rainbow shirts at what store Walmart's
got rainbow shirts Target's got rainbow
shirts they do which beer is queer they
don't give a [__] about that they don't
give a [__] they don't trust me trust me
they don't give a [__] about that
nonsense
they just don't
and don't let them convince you of that
lie that somehow Americans give a [__]
about that stuff
so when we get down to that race it is
important that that margin is as big as
possible so that we can prove not just
to not just to the people who are brain
dead that they're that they're dying off
and their ideology sucks and their
policy sucks and the people they have in
charge of their policies suck even more
but we need to prove it to ourselves
folks ourselves the pro-democracy
Coalition that there is a through line
there is a through line of pro-democracy
principles that people want rights
freedoms and Liberty yes we may disagree
on the amount of amount of wages we may
disagree on on the actual
the extent of unions in labor we may
disagree on how much here or how much
there but that's debates we can have
on a serious level with serious people
in our serious government
but until we get these unserious
fascists out of our government that is
the threat
rather we mock them like the Democrats
laughed at Marjorie Taylor green
yesterday when she gaveled for decorum
in the house and they laughed at her and
laughed and laughed and laughed or we
mock Ron DeSantis and his failed launch
and his failed campaign from the get-go
before he said one word
or we go straight after fascism with
strategic [__] outrage just like I do
here every single weekday Monday through
Friday
that is how we win that is how we get
fascism to crawl back underneath its
Rock
I'll guide you I'll show you the way I
will give you the narrative I'm right on
top of it I know exactly where the
wedges need to be drawn
so stay tuned every single weekday for
two full hours Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch don't forget
to hit the Subscribe button if you're on
YouTube right now go follow us on
Twitter you're gonna get the vote for
bonehead of the week
tonight on Twitter and on YouTube go to
the community tab on YouTube the poll
will be there it'll also be on Twitter
at the Tony Michaels pod and we will
break you vote you decide who is the
bonehead of the week we will break it
down me and my co-host Gabe and Sanchez
tomorrow in the second hour also
download every single episode at Apple
Spotify and Google it's free 99. you get
a five finger discount on the audio
version
the radio version
oh my God
these [__] Elon scents don't know
what radio is whoosh okay you get the
audio or the radio version on Apple
Spotify and Google of the Tony Michaels
podcast go ahead you can download it a
half a million times it won't crash a
half a million times it won't crash
trust me it's radio it's just audio it's
not complicated stuff it's really easy
stuff actually
I'll make it easy for you on Facebook
too if you still have a Facebook account
you can watch the Tony Michaels podcast
at the Tony Michaels go follow us on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels and thank
you to everyone who's shown big support
on Twitch we are very excited about the
twitch support we are very excited about
all the people who are showing up and
watching us on Twitch live we got over
70 people right now viewing live we're
almost to 1200 followers I know that
doesn't sound like a lot but that's big
that's big to us we're a small show and
we're growing fast [__] we are
growing fast and it's because of you it
is because of you and you're here every
single weekday for two full hours make
sure if you have an Amazon Prime account
that you link it to your Twitch account
because you can follow us for free over
on Twitch but it costs money for the
subscription
not if you have an Amazon Prime account
though it doesn't cost you a single
extra nickel if you have an Amazon Prime
account so go to thetonymichaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com there's a
link it's like the fourth one down it
says link Amazon and twitch it shows you
how to do it right there on Amazon
gaming just click that link if you have
a Prime account you'll log into your
Prime account you can tie it to a Twitch
account if you need to open a Twitch
account just go to YouTube you're here
right now maybe after the show and type
in how do I open a Twitch account and
it'll show you how to do it it's really
easy or you can go to
twitch.tv slash the Tony Michaels that's
twitch.tv Tony Michaels and you can open
an account or twitch there link your
Prime account give us that one free
subscription we get a couple bucks
I'm Jeff bezos's money every single
month everyone stick around don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment where
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show you
know what I think I'm gonna do this
afternoon
[Music]
I think today we're going to do an ask
me anything ask me anything and we'll do
it this afternoon I believe
after the show after I get done editing
I got a quick meeting I gotta have I
gotta do an audio video test I think Joe
flood is going to join us tomorrow do
you know you remember the guy on the red
bike
who was a taunting uh Patriot front he's
gonna join us tomorrow on the show
at the bottom of the hour so like right
now this time tomorrow we're gonna we're
gonna bring the red bike guy in Joe
flood who was taunting the Patriot
fronts I just want to get a sense of
what it was like on the ground from him
and the audiences wanted him on the show
we showed a picture of his the other day
of the Ballard that um that the U-Haul
terrorist the U-Haul maganazi terrorist
drove into he uh shot a picture of that
uh there in Washington DC and we showed
it on the show the other day and
everyone said hey get him on get him on
get him on so
um we have been in conversations with
Jill flood and I think I'm doing audio
video tests for him this afternoon so
after I'm done with that after I'm done
editing doing the audio video test I
will do an ask me anything on patreon so
go to patreon.com go to patreon.com the
Tony Michaels that's patreon.com the
Tony Michaels or you can just go to the
Tony michaels.com and the patreon link
is there you just go to the Tony
michaels.com select support Tony on
patreon and it'll take you to the
patreon page you'll be able to join in
on ask me anything ask me anything
that's where we get a little group of
people together you get to ask me
anything I will try to answer every
single question within 30 minutes
we'll do like 30 minutes guys ask
question I'll try to answer it no matter
what the question that's right no matter
what the question you can ask me how
many Margaritas I had last night one two
three four five margaritas
do you remember that I can't get over
there from yesterday that's crazy that's
[__] crazy so hopefully we'll um our
audio test will go well with Joe flood
and we'll have Joe tomorrow uh with us
joining us and hopefully you can come on
more and more and more that would be
great I I love reoccurring guests don't
you guys I love guests that we that come
over and over we have Rachel bidikoffer
we've had Jess Piper
um I I want I want to have
I want to have several guests that we
have all the time back over and over and
over again so hopefully Joe will be one
of those guests we've had Dara Faye and
back several times so I I love having
regular guests it's a it's a thing that
I I continue want to do
um Gabe Sanchez is going to be joining
us here in just a minute and we're going
to mock the holy [__] out of DeSantis
but again
if you want to you know what let's let
me give you a sense of what ask me
anything is like if you want to join
this afternoon while we're waiting on
Gabe Sanchez he has a few things he's
finishing up so at if you have a
question down in uh if you have a
question post it in the chat there I
will try to see if I can get uh if I can
get a couple uh questions answered but
this is kind of what it'll be like
um tonight on the or this afternoon on
ask me anything where you can you can
ask me anything and literally on ask me
anything if you asked a question I try
to answer it within that time what size
is the margarita is the is the question
from Forrest
uh what size I only had I only have one
Margarita last night to be quite honest
only one
and it was a small one usually I have
like a medium-sized one you know like in
the bowl and my favorite Margarita to be
quite honest is uh you know make fun of
me I don't give a [__] is a frozen
strawberry margarita with sugar instead
of salt [__] yourself I want the sugar
around it I want to be like a slushie
[__] that's what I want that's how I
like my Margaritas rather I have one of
them or I have five of them that's the
other thing too I was really confused
about that video and that's one thing we
didn't talk about maybe we should talk
about now how big do these margaritas
have to be you know what I'm saying she
was just uh completely sure
about the number of margaritas right
like she thinks she's got it down to a
[__] science but not all margaritas
are created equal right
they're just not I mean they they might
be Equitable in her scheme of one to
five margaritas and what could happen if
you if you have those margaritas
but you know they might not be equal
Equitable but not equal here's the thing
is I mean you had small ones you got big
ones sometimes you got a stout
Margaritas some games you got a weak
Margarita you know who knows what kind
of tequila you're putting in there I
don't know I'm just saying
we really need to nail down maybe we
should have her on as a guest and figure
out if no one knows what the hell I'm
talking about you're gonna have to go
watch the yesterday's show that's just
it that's just it
oh let's see when you guys got any more
questions haven't heard much about Mark
Meadows do you think he is flipped uh
mark C asked from YouTube do I think
Mark Meadow has flipped no
I think he is pretending to flip he's
probably done several proffers uh for
the feds meaning he's gone in and he's
talked to prosecutors and they explored
the idea of him flipping uh but has he
flipped I don't know I actually think
it's more likely that Ivanka and Jared
is flipped than than Mark Meadows I
think Ivanka and Jared know way more
than maybe even Mark Meadows knows
um did we see the end of that video
oh yeah the end of the video was where
she's talking about pegging
after five Margaritas she'll Peg you and
The Crowd Goes Wild
they're [__] going wild they're
excited yeah look at yeah
and then when we came up with the name
for five margaritas and uh and a stravon
at the bar if we if it's hypothetically
speaking if meaning Abe Sanchez owned a
bar uh
we would serve margaritas and it would
be a pitcher Margaritas plus strap-on
and that would be called a Peggy maybe
you would order a piggy
um that would be
oh you guys with the [__] dirty jokes
and your dirty Margarita jokes you guys
you guys mine's always in the goddamn
always in the goddamn gutter always in
the goddamn gutter
okay
if you want to ask a question other than
Margaritas or
who a Peggy
um
you got me red now see you got me
blushing oh my god
um
you are the best and the funniest damn
audience in the world you really are
okay let's see if we can get Gabe's
inches on your I'm losing I'm losing
track of things
[Laughter]
oh man why is he hiding then someone
asked that Regina on Facebook why is
Mark Meadows hiding I mean why are any
of them hiding you haven't heard from
cash Patel in a long time either you
remember cash Patel was right up front
he was doing interview after interview
after interview after interview as soon
as the documents case came out he was
like no Trump can declassify these
things with his mind and I was there and
people like whoa what prosecutors like
whoa what Jack Smith's like oh yeah
[__]
and cash Patel
promptly shut his mouth I mean there's
still pain
they're still paying
um Paulie asked does Tony have a Discord
we do we do have a Discord the problem
is I don't know what the [__] to do with
it
I don't know what to do with are people
on on um on on Twitch wondering if we
have a Discord because I I mean I would
try to figure it out I don't I don't
really I mean you can go to the Tony
michaels.com just go to the
tonymichaels.com the Discord link is
there if you
um have Discord or want Discord or want
the the Discord that we set up it's
there there's several people that are in
that Discord
um again the link is at the Tony
michaels.com if you are interested in
Discord I don't know much about Discord
I'll be quite honest I don't get on
there a lot Gabe knows a little more
about it than I do
um so I just I can't keep up with every
[__] single social media but I do
know this I do know this in Discord
um it has like a radio thing like
Twitter and it would have been much
probably much better at handling
um Rhonda Santos's launch last night on
Radio like internet radio
because it's kind of like I mean yeah
it's not like broadcast radio but it's
internet radio it's [__] audio how
the hell did they [__] that up right
how do they [__] that up
it's radio and then servers crash and
during the [__] thing you can hear
Elon be like her her sure her servers
are crashing yeah no [__] Sherlock
I I again I don't I don't know if you
guys have been in Twitter spaces but
I've been in several Twitter space it's
glitchy as [__] it crashes all the time
it's kind of dog [__] anyways they know
that it's dog [__] Twitter spaces with
some sort of Twitter experiment that
they didn't even know was gonna [__]
take off or not and the first time they
really did Twitter spaces it was it was
really kind of shitty and you can only
do it on mobile you can listen to it on
desktop but there's no way to stream in
through desktop which is [__]
horrible
they don't give you any way to stream
audio into it you have to just use the
microphone on your phone it's really
stupid
it's [__] stupid now Brad says here
Facebook on Facebook Discord is
basically chat rooms right yeah it's
like a it's like an archived chat room
where uh all the supporters can talk to
each other I can talk to you in there on
Discord
um and really honestly if you guys want
to go over there and you know do some
stuff on Discord I wouldn't be opposed
to learning it I just I don't know it
I'm I'm never gonna [__] [__] you
I don't know Discord where the [__] so
if you want to go on Discord and more
people want to go over there and want to
engage on Discord I'd engage on Discord
that's fine by me you can go again all
the social media links that I'm on are
on my website thetonymichaels.com you go
to the Tony michaels.com if I'm on a
social media it's probably there it
doesn't mean that I engage much on it
but it's there and you can follow me on
and you should like Instagram and
Facebook tick tocks over there I don't
really post much [__] on Tick Tock
anymore because Tick Tock didn't like me
you just don't and that's where I have I
think that's where I have the most
followers is on to be quite honest
but they don't they don't like to show
my videos like I'll post a video in
there and everyone so I get like 5 000
views and sometimes like 200 now I'm
like [__] you
[__] you show it to my audience why
don't they do the algorithm should show
it to your followers if you got a
certain amount of followers it's
ridiculous but whatever I ain't [__] I
I'm not gonna complain about Tick Tock I
don't give a [__]
um but again Discord it is like a chat
room so if you guys want to go over
there and get on Discord go go get on
Discord again the link is at the Tony
michaels.com and you can find the
Discord link there
dude
um
Robin says here and she says Discord has
made some changes okay well then I'll
check it out I'll check it out I'll open
up my desktop Discord app later on today
and maybe we'll do it during the ask me
anything maybe that's where we'll do it
where in the hell
is Sanchez
he says he's got noise in his apartment
because of construction I'm gonna out
him
noisy and you know it happens it's live
it's live TV it's live
where's chips and giggles at okay let's
just go to some videos because I got
some stuff I want to show you guys uh
let's check in on the trial or the
sentencing hearing of Stuart Rhodes
has it been announced
um okay the judge is speaking apparently
about four minutes ago the judge said
this let me uh pull this up
here's from Scott McFarlane he says uh
the judge says uh Mr Rhodes you were
convicted of seditious conspiracy you're
a lawyer you understand what this means
judge discusses history of seditious
conspiracy dating back to the Civil War
era uh quote a seditious conspiracy is
among the most serious crimes an
individual American can commit it's an
offense against the government to use
Force it's a defense against the people
of the country the judge says and what
is the motive you didn't like the new
guy referencing Joe Biden so the judge
is speaking right now currently as we
speak and what the judge will do
um I've experienced this before the
judge will give a speech he'll give his
opinion right he'll give his little
diatribe on what and why he's going to
give the sentence and why his his uh
um uh his points for the sentence will
be and then he will lay down the
sentence to uh Stuart Rhodes he will
more than likely gavel uh the hearing
closed and Stuart Rhodes will be toted
off into an orange jumpsuit because you
got to remember Stewart Rhodes is in an
orange jumpsuit in the courtroom because
he has been detained on his pre-trial
since he was arrested and his post-trial
awaiting his sentencing and then he will
he will then he will then be released
into the custody of b.o.p soon after now
they process him for his sentencing
because Bop actually carries out the
sentence so let's let's say uh I'm
correct let's say I'm correct and that
the um the judge gives him a dirty 30.
which here's what a dirty 30 is okay
um here here's more from here's more
from the judge
um the judge says we cannot have a group
of citizens who be um because they
didn't like the outcome of election are
then prepared to take up arms to forment
a revolution that's what you did oh my
God uh-oh you are not a political
prisoner Mr Rhodes uh the judge replies
in his speech the judge says 12 jurors
in The District Columbia convicted U.S
Edition this was a juror of your peers
make no mistake about it the judge then
goes on to say 25 seconds
um here he says we all now hold our
Collective breasts with the election
approaching
we will have another January 6 question
mark it remains to be seen
um so the judge not only not only is the
judge replying to the past events but
maybe future events like January 6 that
could happen uh the and McFarland goes
on to report here as the judge is just
Rising raised the fear of uh felt by
some a number of Americans about the
Outlook of the aftermath of the 2024
election the judge says quote we will
now hold our Collective breaths with an
election approaching will there be
another oh that's the one I just read
sorry
uh let's see is there any more judge uh
uh keeps going to the same one I'm
trying to find follow the thread here as
we go along
um so
oh boy it's not going well for Stuart
Rhodes it doesn't look well for Stuart
Rhodes uh in this situation and what a
dirty 30 is I keep saying that dirty 30
is 20 years in prison 20 years PR excuse
me 10 years probation and sort of 30
comes in dirty 30 they call it now the
prosecution is asking for 25 years
that's what they're asking for uh Stuart
Rhodes is sentencing guidelines is
between 21 and 27 years I believe
at his sentencing guideline
is between 21 and 27 years so we will
see
um if we have if we have
um what he is sentencing will be here in
the next few moments and it looks like
the judge is going to lay it down here
very soon now the judge uh Scott goes on
to say the judge discusses Rhodes 58
personal and professional background
including roads military service
and his law degree from Yale did you
know that
that Stuart Rhodes has a Yale law degree
Stuart Rhodes is a [__] Ivy League
school Elite
put that wrap your [__] head around
then
the guy who is responsible for Leading
The Oath Keepers to seditious conspiracy
for Donald Trump a man of the people
a man of the people is a Yale
Yale educated lawyer
come on man if I can break
give me a [__] break
um oh yes I I wanna I wanna mention too
why why we're talking about steel roads
um because I've interviewed Stewart's
son Dakota Adams Dakota Von Adams
and his uh ex-wife now ex-wife Tasha
Adams and she actually finalized her
divorce just the other day
um I posted that video they post the
video they went to the courthouse and
and so now Stuart Rhodes is not only
gonna go to prison for a long time but
he's divorced have you been following
this news gate Sanchez looks like
Stewart Rhodes is going to get the
sentence here
um pretty goddamn quickly now let's see
if um
if the judges laid it down he's giving
his speech here uh the judge goes on to
say Scott's reporting from inside the
courtroom here uh Gabe he says it's
really not my job to pass judgment on
The Oath Keepers organization it's my
job uh it's my job to pass judgment on
Mr Rhodes the judge blast roads were
turning positive attributes against the
country
um so we'll see here it's it's coming
very close to uh Stuart Rhodes getting
getting handed down the sentence yeah or
seditious conspiracy the craziest part
uh so far the two craziest parts that I
think is that
um that still Rhodes's defense team
during their argument a why the judge
should lower the sentence for Stuart
Rhodes as it was Donald Trump's idea for
the Insurrection like literally they
were like look none of this would have
happened if Donald Trump wouldn't have
tweeted on December 19 2020. I mean look
if Stuart Rhodes and his team want to
throw Donald Trump under the bus and
they have more evidence that they want
to provide not that it's going to get
Stuart Rhodes you know off the hook but
if he's got stuff he wants to show for
his defense by all means double back do
it yeah get the [__] [__] well
the other the other thing that's crazy
to me is Stewart Rhodes actually spoke
and he thought it was a good idea to say
that he was a political prisoner and the
judge rebuts it in his speech
like like real time yeah real time is
well I mean because Stuart Rhodes gave
his remarks and down the judge is giving
his remarks to lay down the sentence he
says you are not a political prisoner
you committed sedition which is one of
the worst acts that an American can and
you were you were you were seen Guilty
by a jury of your peers and convicted
friend so no you don't you're not a
political prisoner this is not some
political Witch Hunt this is this is
federal court now you can have your
opinion about Justice in this country
and the feds and the Department of
Justice and the court system and the Bop
I have a lot of opinions of that and not
all of them are favorable let me tell
you it's not all favorable I actually
believe the two-tier system that Maga
has been bitching about the last [__]
six months actually exist and they're
just mad that it's not going to protect
people like Donald Trump or Stuart
Rhodes anymore yeah that's the other
crazy part about this is the judge
brought up that hey Stewart look you are
a lawyer you were educated at Yale and
that's the funniest part is downshot
supposed to be this man of the people
the man of the average person right and
one of the spearheaded groups of The
Oath Keepers to go over overthrow the
government for him when he declared
martial law
the head of IT the founder and the
person who is leading the charge that
day with The Oath Keepers there in
Washington met with the proud boys for
crying out loud the night before the
Enrique atario who is also wait wait are
you telling me now obviously I I know
that uh he went to Yale and we learned
those things when we had the interview
with Tasha and Dakota yeah and if anyone
hasn't watched that from last year 2021
2020 no 2022 yeah yeah right I forget
anyway it's it's it's been a lot it's
been a while but in that interview it's
great they reveal some stuff they talk
about stuff they talk about the whole
lot eye situation for Stuart
but you know now that which is hilarious
by the way oh yeah yeah
now now when I think about it are you
telling me
that the leader
of The Oath Keepers is an elitist
that's what I just said on yeah that's
what the judges alluding to I think that
looks
East Coast elitist right right it may
that may not been how he was born that
may not been how he is raised but that's
where his degree is from that's where
his degree is from so [__] you with this
stupid [__] that that that it's leftists
that are a [__] elitist it's your
leadest who [__] founded The Oath
Keepers who is being sentenced today
more than likely to 2030 maybe even more
with uh princess sentence and probation
I think he's going to get a dirty 30. I
really think the judge is going to give
him 20 years plus 10 years probations
what he's going to give him here okay so
people well quickly people want to know
how he lost his eye and I'll give you
the TLD oh yeah okay yeah go ahead so
Vanity Fair I think did an article and
they said this is wrong by the way they
got it wrong he did he did teach uh we
were the ones who broke the story though
yeah yeah we were the one that broke the
story the way the way that it goes is
they were like back in 93 or what
whatever
uh he shot his eye out at a firing range
as an instructor those are two separate
events he was an instructor at a firing
range however
to get all the all the [__] tea and
all the gossip you definitely have to
watch the interview because Tasha talks
about what happened but basically he
shot his own eye out by mistake with the
gun that he had uh basically what she
alluded to was there was probably
dropped it and it was like it's like a
bad drug deal right yeah yeah but the
the whole all of the details they gave
into it are are worth it you should go
back we'll we'll put it in the
description if you guys want to watch
the interview it's so good you actually
if you go to the YouTube channel you go
to playlist you just go to Oat Keepers
and proud boys playlist and it that that
interview with Tasha perfect there you
go and Dakota's there I I got some news
on this uh the judge um emphasizes this
this is important that this judge is
saying this because this is different
from what the defense team of Stuart
Rhodes was saying the judge emphasizes
that those who were called the
Washington by roads quote bear
responsibility for their actions uh end
quote he also but he says they were also
victims of lies and propaganda so there
they're saying that Trump wasn't
actually leading them there
um here is uh and here's here's the
statement before that I I did it
backwards there sorry about that it says
judge says dozens came to Washington
with some weapons he's alluding to
um the weapons that were stored across
the Potomac to quote fight in the
streets end quote because of Roads the
quote here is it happens only only
because of you Mr Rhodes so the judge in
his sentencing remarks here is not
blaming Donald Trump for the seditious
conspiracy he is saying it happened only
because of you Mr Rhodes he's
emphasizing again that that yes they
bear the responsibility actions but
they're victims of lies and propaganda
so
um not the judge isn't exactly blame the
judge isn't exactly blaming Trump here
what I'm sorry you just dropped me you
just drive hit the road
yeah yeah well
man ah damn uh let's see I'm waiting to
see I'm I'm following this thread
because Scott is typing it in like as
it's going so I'm waiting uh to break
the news here um of of stewards but why
we wait um for that uh and and that is a
great story by the way oh it's so good
so good so yes and the reason why the
reason why where's the eye patch and he
lost and is it's so nasty because he has
like are you used to have a glass side
but they tell the story about how he
kept it in way too long and he never
would wash it and it got nasty and it
got infected yeah and his eye socket
like got infected so he can't wear of he
can't wear a fake eye anymore that's
where he has to wear the iPad yeah
that's why that's the whole thing so
yeah got it wrong he didn't shoot his
eye out at a firing range
gun safety it was like a drug deal gone
bad in some Warehouse or something like
that and basically it sounds like he
dropped the gun and it was like a
misfire and boom shot him in the eye and
that
is is the real story but definitely
listen to the interview because
in it she goes into all these other
details of everything else Dakota talks
about the tunnels they dug in the
backyards oh it was so good yeah it is
good it is good you guys you guys and go
watch all the interviews with Dakota
because we've had Dakota on several
times
um
Scott goes on to say here two minutes
ago he tweeted I've heard uh judge Matha
I think that or Mita uh issue other
January six sentences this is next level
is what Scott is saying this is his
reporting particularly stirring sobering
and more stern than any I've ever seen
in the January 6 case uh he goes on to
say Rhodes is sitting slumped down a bit
in this chair occasionally taking notes
as the judge unloads this skating
criticism
um we're gonna get to Here We Go flash
uh judge sentences Stewart Rhodes to 18
years in prison 18 years so I was off by
The Mark of two years I said he'd get a
dirty 30. no what the
oh there we go damn it what are you
doing what's going on
I'm I'm trying man I'm trying to go here
okay Pierce The Flash here's the judge
sentences Stewart Rose to 18 years in
prison for seditious conspiracy
um thank you Scott for being in the
courtroom so that's the news now I'm
breaking it here on the Tony Michaels
podcast through skip Scott
McFarland's Twitter page Jesus Christ is
it Monday or something [__] I don't know
man you're uh you're I believe you went
out for karaoke Wednesday man so yeah
that could be what the hell the problem
is yeah it could be what the problem is
so and breaking news uh it looks like
Stewart Rhodes is going to get 18 years
in a federal prison my guess is he'll
get five seven ten years of probation so
he'll he'll receive almost uh the full
30 years of sentencing so I was a little
off I figured to get 20 and then 10
which they call it a dirty 30. that's
why I posted that but he's getting 18
years 18 years what's your first
reaction to 18 years in prison I mean
not long enough all right all right yeah
I mean look I mean 18 years is uh the
longest that we've seen right [__] uh
this is the biggest January right I mean
I think the closest yes but the closest
one to that was okay yeah here's more
here's more more news the sentence was
216 months in prison with a three years
supervised after so he's gonna get three
years of so 21 years of money 21 years
of supervised and prison
um because the other one the other one
that we got was
uh four years and that was Big O
um that was the guy who put his feet on
Nancy Pelosi's desk yes and said and
stole and stole documents yeah he's
still he still let her I mean which
technically is a federal crime uh he's
still her male and they wrote a letter
that said something like something about
[__] Pelosi right yeah it's something
there's a video of him saying it and
they actually played in there he's out
yeah outside uh here's Richard's Big O
Barnett here's Scott uh right here
um giving and he said quite possibly his
estimated release date could reach near
the 2040s so it'll be near it'll be in
the 20 late 20s 30s or the 2040s before
Stuart Rhodes would release and that's
the other thing too is a lot of people
this is a federal sentence so
um there's no parole like there's no
getting out early now you have good time
what they call a good time in the
federal prison system where you get so
many days per year that you actually are
sentenced if you don't lose it so if you
don't lose your good time you don't [__]
up you don't break any rules and you'll
get good time off your sentence but
that's still you still even if you have
good time you're still going to serve
your 18 years and your three years a
supervised release it's very unlikely
that he'll that he'll be released much
earlier right um that you know it's
possible he'll be out he'll be out with
an ankle bracelet on good behavior in 16
years maybe 15 16 years uh depends on
the rule I know
the prison bill that Trump passed which
you know honestly that's one of the only
reasonable things that Trump did during
his presidency uh I don't think he went
far enough with it but you know that's
just my personal do we have an idea of
where you like do you have an idea of
where you think he'll serve his time
well he's from he was he was staying in
taxes so
um generally and that's one thing that
that bill did that Trump signed is they
don't give you what's called windshield
time or or our Con Air Time which means
you have to be somewhere close within
the vicinity of of your family or or
your home you know uh it used to be the
Bop if they didn't [__] like you and
let's say you're from Florida they were
like oh you want to be a [__] we'll
send you to California right right and
what it does is it isolates you well he
doesn't have any family anywhere close
there man well Tasha just got a divorce
they're free of that guy and he's gonna
have he's gonna have a lot of [__]
he's gonna have a lot of weird
supporters he's going to be Stewart
Rhodes will probably be a pen pal for a
lot of [__] seditious [__] Nazis
for years to come and he will pump
propaganda out there and you will see it
circling on the internet yeah but how
much of how much of that because
obviously letters and such are like
they're opened and reviewed and they're
looked at and everything's you know yeah
so so when you when when you're when
you're locked up in a federal prison you
have access to mail they it is a right
yeah it is it's actually granted by the
Supreme Court two prisoners they you ha
they cannot stop your mail now they can
review your mail in and out but they
can't stop now there are certain things
like certain books and certain things
that you can't send in but letters in
mail they cannot stop so are you telling
me if somebody or he decided for
whatever reason to make some crazy Claim
about something they were going to do
they would let that they would let the
letter through they wouldn't stop well I
mean it they can review it and they can
stop it now uh based on and he can sue
them if they do stop his mail too much
for what he's saying the other thing
that that inmates in in federal
penitentiaries generally have access to
depends on the facility
um they have access to email and it's a
weird email system it takes forever it's
like on a three hour delay so like when
when someone sends you an email they
send you an email in this system and it
holds it for like their three hours and
then you get it and then once you get
the email you can respond to the email
it takes like three [__] hours for
that person to receive it right yeah and
and all that is to filter it now I think
they use different um automated filters
and they use human filters to look
through these emails because they don't
want
federal inmates committing crime while
they're in a federal prison the other
thing you have access to is a phone but
most of the federal penitentiaries limit
your access to how many hours a month
you can talk on the phone so there are
ways and we've seen this with a Gateway
pundit yeah where he's done interviews
and that's he's done those interviews
through his phone time that he was given
that he's granted as his right as a as
an inmate to talk the other thing too is
visits your right to visits now they can
they can stop your visits but uh Stuart
Rhodes will have the ability to request
people uh whatever facility that he's at
to have them be approved visitors so you
can get business visiting time as long
as he's you know being good and being a
good boy and the federal penitentiary
that he's going to be in now he can
actually receive visitors so there's
several ways for Stuart Rhodes to really
uh get get his get his propaganda out
there and I know he will because that's
always been his his thing that's why
he's done these interviews with Gateway
pundit with his phone time in federal
prison the other thing that they can't
stop is legal visits so he will he will
be able to meet with his legal team uh
usually in in a different location than
what you would normally have visits
um and and because they can't impede on
certain legal visits from his attorneys
um so I would imagine that sewer roads
will probably have many legal visits
especially have to do with the appeal
this case because I'm sure he's going to
try to appeal this case over and over
and over again and the other thing that
that the Stuart Rhodes will continue to
do is he will continue in the federal
penitentiary that he's in uh be tapping
the law library
um every federal penitentiary has a law
library to some degree and you're not
going to do them any good but well you
had the jailhouse lawyers that's that
that help other people with their cases
their appeals because they don't have
attorneys and uh and I say jailhouse
lawyers because some of them are actual
lawyers or were lawyers and some of them
are thank their lawyers and they're not
lawyers at all but Stewart Rhodes was a
lawyer at one point so he does know the
law and the judge wanted and out uh in
his sentencing uh today so that's that's
kind of the long and the short of what
Stuart Rhodes's life is going to look
like let's see if there's any more
um updates from here now the judge is
probably going to close this and and
sure roads is going to be toted off um
Scott here says the judge not only
blasted roads for his role in a historic
American Horror but he also expressed a
fear about what happens next after the
2024 election a sobering and visceral
moment in the courthouse so in the
judge's speech not only did he did he
did he come down hard on roads not just
with the convict and the sentence but
with the rhetoric that the judge wanted
to say hey you tried to overturn our
government you're not a political
prisoner you were convicted by a jury of
your peers I am sentencing you because
you were responsible for this and I am
afraid and other Americans are afraid if
we don't sentence you what could happen
after the next election
and what is to come so uh more uh on
this probably as as we go like where
he'll go now it'll take a little bit for
like the bop to designate where Stuart
Rhodes is going to go but I would
imagine
um we'll hear within the next month of
exactly where he'll he'll serve the
initial part of his time right because
it's likely he could get transferred
around from facility to facility and
also it depends on how high up in the
system he starts this is seditious
conspiracy so it is likely that Stuart
Rhodes could go to a higher level prison
but still roads is kind of old so I
would imagine he'll go to
um a medium or a medium low or a low
yeah prison but he will he will have con
he will be in a prison with controlled
movements
um and he probably will never lead
prison that doesn't have controlled
movements so yeah
um that is probably for sure so that's
enough about Stu roach [__] that guy
[__] that seditious could that [__]
piece of treasonous garbage hey let's
talk about another piece reason is
garbage
ah they're everywhere aren't they oh man
we got we got an hour left
is that enough time to talk about what
the hell happened last night yeah I'm
happy to talk about what happened
yesterday oh my God so tell the audience
the big news last night uh the crash and
burn on Twitter because we were both
listening you were listening in elon's
room right yeah yeah so yeah I was in
Mario's room right right and they were
trying to stream it there so basically
what happened was
the way that Elon Musk is trying to
pitch this right now is that he was like
there were over 500 600 000 people that
were trying to get access to the space
at one time
what the f how how is listen I know that
sounds like a lot of people but it's not
a lot of people Gabe Sanchez that's not
a lot of people I mean because here's
here's the thing right you've got uh if
you were in here let's take a step back
the reason Ron DeSantis decided to do a
Twitter space and this is what I believe
I don't know what other people believe
but this is what I believe Ron DeSantis
is the most boring vanilla
Android robotic body snatching
Republican out there the guy has no
personality the guy has nothing to his
name he tries to talk about his wife a
lot it's really [__] weird Casey
DeSantis trying to do the [__] Jackie
O thing it's weird it's been done before
don't try to copy it but that's
literally all Republicans do they say
copy paste copy paste copy paste and
then when when you have a lot of copy
paste goes on there's gonna be a [__]
glitch that happens this something does
not pace the right way and with Ron
DeSantis
if you look through the whole campaign
right in 2018 he struggled he bitched
and moaned as he practiced for his inner
for his uh for his debates in 2022 he
was terrible he wouldn't openly say if
he would uh continue his or uh go
throughout the whole four-year term of
of his his final term as Governor right
when Charlie Crist asked him right and
the reason being he was going to run for
president in 2024.
so what I see happen is that Ron
DeSantis went to Iowa went to New
Hampshire went to International and he
got [__] dragged right he couldn't
answer stuff he was not he was not ready
for prime time he couldn't answer
questions he couldn't give feedback he
was like oh haha that smells good oh
we're going over here okay let's go flip
some burgers uh well hi my name's Tim
okay uh if well I'll I'll I'll decide if
I'm gonna run for president and it's
like we all knew he was going to run for
president okay the fact that he had
private donors paying for the plane
rides from from Florida to other states
to International right all of these
things
[__] little little spark little
little like oh this is exciting look
he's on the International Space none of
that every time he went somewhere
Jerusalem Tokyo [__] dragged every
single time all like a wet fart and a
white thong it was oh my God so every
time he goes to one of these places he's
hoping he's like I'm gonna make a splash
I'm gonna meet these blue-collar Midwest
or average American people [__] [__]
the block meatball like what's that song
like oh no I lost my meatball and run
down the hill that whole song the
spaghetti song yeah yeah yeah I forget
how it goes but the spaghetti song with
the oh no I lost my meatball and went
down you know whatever the [__] that's
Rhonda santis Rhonda santis is wrong
with that [__] song go now you got me
[__] I don't know I'm sure somebody will
put the song lyrics in here once I see
the lyrics I don't know then you'll know
the Ditty yeah but basically what
happened was all of this [__] that he
tried to do on top of spaghetti they're
already doing
spaghetti
right yeah anyway so I
[Music]
[Laughter]
so all of this stuff nothing nothing
made a splash nothing was like oh man
look at this guy he's on there in the
campaign Trail all this [__] [__]
ain't nothing [__] dragged boring
super super boring so Ron DeSantis
decides and again this is my belief is
that Rhonda Santos was like oh look I'm
not going to do the normal thing that
everyone else does I'm not gonna go on
TV and be on Capital steps like you know
friends people would do it 2023 right
despite the fact that probably majority
of my voters are people who watch TV
right he's like oh no no what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to go onto Twitter and
I'm going to do a Twitter space
okay uh little unorthodox but you know
it seems like you're trying to inject
some new some fun something yeah you
know he's like I'm tech savvy let's do
this Twitter space yeah let's see on
texting yesterday they you know the it's
like uh preparing to launch was the
title of elon's Twitter space right so I
go in there at like three you know
that's kind of funny that's kind of
funny let's stop there that's kind of
funny that Elon Musk his [__] Twitter
space on his account was prepared lunch
when the last actual launch that the guy
did ended in unvoluntary spontaneous
combustion that would they call that or
some [__] yeah they made some BS name
for them
rocket blew up is amazing because in the
what was that that I did that launched
yesterday launched yesterday I made the
joke I was like I don't have to watch
this thing to know it's gonna go about
as well as one of elon's rockets and
then I played the video and then sure
enough the [__] thing bombed and what
happened was they were trying to connect
like oh no 500 600 000 people try to get
on the Twitter space at the same time
okay also if you're Twitter and your
[__] push is that you're gonna uh
you're gonna use Twitter space as a way
to have the Town Square meeting and
stuff like that you better be able to
[__] handle that type of traffic is
the Twitter users are there
uh daily active let's see yeah daily
active Twitter users what what is that
number
I mean because that matters in this in
this context as of March 1st it was 237
million okay 238 million listen to that
200 over 200 million that's daily users
that's not that's not accounts that's
date losers and that's a real number of
how many people are on and even if you
looked at the US which is 79.6 so
roughly 80 million
a million people on the spaces right
think about that in the context of how
many Twitter users there are and they
weren't prepared for this they got to
know what their loads are right they
have to they got to know like okay our
load for the US which was going to be
the highest load for this I mean I mean
I don't know they're tiny D loads wow
right but they're load their load for
this was going to be the US mainly right
so they knew that there was going to be
70 million users that were pot that they
were possibly a percentage of that was
going to have to have to be able to load
for this to have the servers prepared to
have these people on the space they got
to a half a million votes and I just
want to give you the context of this
every single day in this country
um radio like the [__] old ones on
the desk or in your car okay those
radios which is audio which is Twitter
spaces I don't give a [__] what you say
it's audio it's radio [__] okay
every single day there are people who
broadcast from a single [__] Studio
kind of like we do yeah and they
broadcast with syndication all over the
[__] country to millions
millions of radios and Elon claims that
he is the genius of all Geniuses they
knew the load and they weren't prepared
to hold a half a million people and
honestly I think a half a million people
on this space is laughable and the
reason why is because probably at least
a quarter of them were there to laugh
when it [__] failed well not only
that but you also have to remember that
Elon Musk has the most he's like over
140 million users or something like that
let me see uh you mean followers on his
on his account yeah yeah so is that what
is that is that do you think they used
his account for that reason yes 100
because they wanted to get as many
people as they possibly could only
grabbed the half a million people yeah
that's so pathetic so that's why so you
have 140.8 million people that follow
Elon Musk on Twitter right
if I was going to partner with anyone it
would be with the most followed person
on Twitter we would think so yeah I mean
you're right that would be your logic
right and so you make that partnership
and you say hey we're going to go on
there and you interview me but it's also
going to be moderated by David sacks and
yeah listen the Elon stuff was really
weird he even invoked Nazis at one point
I'm like what the [__] why would you why
would you and he's like why would you
say Nazis during a presidential
announcement what's crazy is he said it
in this context he's like and I can't do
Elon very well but he's like because I'm
not an Android but he's like
oh everyone thinks that that anyone who
listens on Twitter spaces are Nazis I'm
like whoa dude what the [__] yeah like I
don't know why you would bring like why
would you I did not think that I did not
think that before here why did you say
that but the fact that you brought it up
and it was really awkward he's like
and then and then it was Ron desantis's
time to speak after that he didn't know
what to say so sounds jumps in how do
you respond man if somebody makes look
you're like hey I'm gonna do this thing
and I'm gonna make this announcement
even though the fact that everyone knew
I was gonna announce I was running for
president because I I made an
announcement about making an
announcement
the Fanfare of the announcement's
already over
what this was it wasn't an announcement
it was like a [__] Round Table he
brought a team of people with him to
speak on stage instead of being like hey
because it was all scripted it was all
stupid yeah I mean even though they were
like oh no not scripted it's going to be
awesome well Elon wasn't scripted
clearly because he kept saying [__] and
like shut the [__] up man you're not the
one running for president you're just
here to host the space and you can't
even you couldn't even do that with me
which again I didn't even understand so
Elon was there talking but David sacks
was supposed to be moderating and asking
questions so like what the purpose is
[__] Elon supposed to be right but
then it was supposed to be account but
Elon can't do anything without his ego
getting in there right exactly so they
do this thing and what ends up happening
is you're like I think you texted me
that you were listening to Mario's room
so I was like okay and I was I was I was
like I can't get anything and I know
that Twitter spaces is glitchy sometimes
like sometimes I'll listen on my phone
and it'll be like someone I can hear and
then someone I can't hear so I was like
all right whatever I'm going to leave
I'm gonna kill the app so I went back in
well I want to go back to the Mario's
room thing yeah I think one of the
reasons why because
um while I was in the room because they
were gonna pump the audio through
another person's microphone in that room
so you could hear what was going on in
elon's room in that room because Twitter
space is it's such [__] trash and
really even when we broadcast on Twitter
it's [__] trash because it's it's
it's on the back of the old Periscope
thing and it's just what's left of it
which is [__] garbage so like you
can't interact with people on there it's
it's just it's [__] clunky it's not
it's not a very good project really but
here's what I'll tell you is that in
Mario's room they couldn't get the audio
and and they kept saying hey folks it's
not us it's [__] elon's it's crazy I
mean you can hear the feedback and like
this like signal coming from yeah it was
so so then so once they discovered that
it was gonna crash and they were gonna
have to try to reset on elon's account
and then I think they actually went the
sax account then they went to David
Zach's account which is a smaller
account too right so then then
then Elon but should but Elon provided a
link to David Sax's account which still
was having here's the thing does it
matter which account that the servers
hold it no that's what I'm saying why
it's all the same place that's one thing
Elon is like oh it must have been my
account like what it's the same
[__] plan it's the same Twitter
it's the same thing so like I mean you
you've he's probably got Engineers on it
at that time to be like oh [__] so
what's going on so they're like oh maybe
they should have got the engineers I
don't know a couple days ago to make
sure they could help or maybe they
shouldn't have cut the engineers from
the beginning
that would be a good idea to have people
actually work there that can fix
problems on the go and on the Fly that'd
be like oh I made a great business
decision to cut all of these jobs yeah
and then I was gonna have this fantastic
oh man
worked out terrific I mean
your decisions are yeah you the art of
the deal as good as Trump right let me
let me show you uh before we go any
further because I want to give you a
comparison and people on twitch will
know this Hassan ABI Assan the Hun on
Twitter are son [__] as he's known
several ways but he tweeted last night
and he was in he was actually in Mario
space for a bit right because I think a
lot of people were trying to get into
Elon space but they couldn't like he
couldn't get because it was so loaded he
couldn't get in he couldn't get in his
face so Mario's room had like 50 000 60
70 000 at one point and they're waiting
to listen but they were just listening
to us talk back and forth because I was
on stage for a minute but then it kept
glitching and it kicked a bunch of
people off the stage it was a [__]
mess really honestly I've never been in
a Twitter space that was such a [__]
mess and that stayed open most time they
crash and they just close but assigned
tweets here this was in real time he
said laugh my ass off I've had 225
000 live co-currents no problem on my
individual twitch Channel now what
co-currence mean is that means at one
point yeah not not overall because like
um like our daily average go current is
like anywhere between 13 1400 sometimes
1200 sometimes a little higher I think
today it's a little higher we'll have
that many coccurrence on our YouTube but
there's concurrence on all the platforms
concurrence
um he had 225 000 yeah a lot of people
that's a lot of people that's half of
what Elon had in his space for a
Presidential nominee our announcement
like that's it here 225 and people
online were like oh because I made my
statement yesterday was like um
I said something to the effect of
uh this thing is you know this thing is
funny it's a flop right there's low
turnout
it keeps glitching
um there's a correction here sicko fits
on YouTube says it's [__] current I want
to make sure I get that correction right
it's [__] okay
that's right and David same thing is
better it is oh well correct we'll
correct it's [__] current we'll send it
to uh [__] Webster Miriam right make
sure they change that and YouTube and
all the platforms make sure they change
so here here's and I what I said
yesterday was like it was a low low
turnout
uh
audio kept cutting out and the app
twitter twitter spaces kept crashing the
app right if you're like oh low turnout
what he's got like half a million people
and I'm like look that's not a lot what
I mean what I mean is this low turnout
for this type of event yes
okay
he is supposed to be the person that can
and might beat Donald Trump in the
presidential election of Maga who is
supposed to be a representation of half
the country which is a [__] lie
anyways you dumb [__] are you
listening look look
Hassan which not even half the country
knows who Hassan is he's very popular
with Gen Z he's very popular on Twitch
he's probably one of the most popular
um people on Twitch he had 225 which is
half on his individual Twitch account no
problem and the reason why is because I
don't know twitch makes sure that they
have loads that they can handle this
amount of users and here's the thing
you mean they gotta make sure Twitter
spaces can hold a certain amount of
people before they put that certain
amount of people on there are you
kidding me crazy without a problem give
me a break you're talking about you're
talking about all kinds of work really
and when you don't have any money in
blood to Twitter like you said that's
going to be difficult but Hassan goes on
to say he says meanwhile Twitter spaces
can't handle 270
000 people just awful hilarious and it
is hilarious they not only did Ron
DeSantis [__] the bet on his launch and
I have no idea why he penned all his
hopes on [__] Elon what the [__] did
Elon have to say to oh there's a ghost
[__] Elon what did Elon have to say
to him to convince him to do this number
one but why in the [__] would anyone
trust Elon Musk on Twitter at all like
have they not been watching the last six
eight months right I mean come on man it
isn't making it hold on let me let me
close this door real quick oh my God
yeah go ahead go ahead close your damn
door it's not gonna no one cares that
your dog walked in they really don't
unless you don't want to disturb someone
in the other room he's closing door I'm
gonna I'm gonna bring him back on I
don't give a [__] look at him yeah there
he is
[Laughter]
he came back from the walk and was like
okay what's going on in here he does the
same thing like if I'm in the bathroom
I'm doing my own thing he just pops in
and he's like he's like hey man what's
up man just see what turns around and he
leaves but I'm too far from the door
closing so now the door is completely so
you're taking a [__] with the door open
is what you're saying pretty much yeah
that happens that happens when you got
dogs that happens it happens but back
back yeah
this Twitter flop of an event right
because that's what it is and not only
that so he he did the Twitter space and
then at one point they were like oh well
David and I and Elon were sitting next
to each other so we'll actually just do
it on David's account now because it
seems to be causing issues no look if
you're gonna do something like this that
you have now you have you have he was
literally in an interview with the Wall
Street Journal editorial the day before
two days ago
the day before this happened and he was
like oh yeah I'm gonna be doing a a
pretty big announcement with Ron
DeSantis you're going to want to tune in
uh it's going to be kind of historical
if you start saying big event historical
I'm gonna be there this versus gonna be
oh it was historical hysterical
historical it was hysterical but you
better make sure that you can actually
support the thing that you're promising
So when you say what are you talking
about Elon come on are you serious his
[__] his [__] cars spontaneously
combust his rocket spontaneous like a
bus that's why I'm saying why the [__]
do you trust him you know the best part
about this yeah is the trolling from not
only Joe Biden because Joe Biden posted
a link almost immediately to his act
blue and said this works I had people
that commented and they're like oh yeah
it's working because uh nobody goes to
it and I was like no it's working
because the platform act blue or
wherever the donations go to they
actually know to handle that much
traffic right they they have a certain
amount of load that they know they're
going to handle and then someone's like
oh it's not a link and I'm like dude I'm
not even gonna
send you to elon's tweet that literally
is a [__] link of David Sax's Twitter
space
you [__] idiots [__] boneheads but
the trolling from Donald Trump listen
and I text you this last night I'm like
man I I I've never been on the Trump
train but last night I was like choo
choo [__]
it was hilarious oh my God you gotta see
this [__] actually posted this
on true social this now this is a this
is this is not real because it's got
It's got Dick Cheney George Soros Adolf
Hitler the FBI and the devil and
was like
post it post it post it this is great
and I'm gonna show you the Ben Shapiro
tweet after this video and how stupid
how stupid the right is and this is why
Donald Trump is the king of the
stupidity is this right here watch this
this is [__] hilarious but this this
is the guy who's gonna be the nominee
for the Republican Party who is going to
wipe the floor with Ron DeSantis who
last night tried to seriously launch his
campaign and crashed and burned this is
what he posted to Market
hi everyone Welcome to our Rhonda
Sanders Twitter space Hello is my
microphone working correctly George can
you just wait while we hello can you
hear me we can all hear you George can
you just hold on for a second I don't
think they can hear me
I don't think George knows how to use
Twitter hello uh can you hear me now can
I please make my big announcement now
everyone just hello just shut up George
can somebody just mute George
for anyone who's wondering that's Dick
Cheney coughing into the microphone dude
I don't know who they got to do these
Impressions last minute but this is or
or or if somebody was using somebody
else who could have been using a voice
AI thing as well which I might probably
is more realistic but oh my God this is
hilarious it it's a cough
okay so how are we gonna take out Trump
you guys uh
guys from the FBI this is not a private
call this is a public Twitter space
everyone can listen in
God damn it and they drop
uh anyway guys we invited everyone to
this uh this Twitter space so Governor
Ron DeSantis could everyone just shut
the hell
the hell okay you go girl wait the devil
is gay so what everyone in this call is
gay
yeah
yeah guys can we please just calm down
so anyway guys I just wanted to announce
that I'm okay I can hear the governor
very well shut up would you please shut
up already I'm running for [__]
president okay yeah we kind of already
congratulations governor
uh well that concludes our Twitter space
for today thank you to all of our hold
your horses Elon the real president is
gonna all right I'm cutting it there
because oh my God I'm telling you this
is listen and and it's funny as [__]
yeah it's funny it's hilarious it's
hilarious but this is what Ron DeSantis
is up against Gabe Sanchez yeah he's up
against this kind of mockery this is why
we are so good at mocking the right and
and Donald Trump did a brilliant job
last night of destroying Ron DeSantis
with this one little video and I know it
feels like oh it's just funny no do you
see the other two that he made no I I
didn't I didn't see the other two give
me give me give me the links find him on
Twitter if you can it might be easier
for me to blame him there than on true
social if you can but here's the thing
is that I've been saying this for
[__] months that Donald Trump's going
to be the candidate and this is why is
because Republic the Republican party is
scrapes the bottom of the barrel and
really it's the cult mentality and and
Rhonda santis is not going to break the
cult away from Donald Trump he's just
not gonna do it I mean no one is Tim
Scott Nikki Haley they're not gonna
break away the cult from Trump you're
just not because they love this type of
[__] they actually want this
[__] to be president who made
this video and who posted on his
official social media account now I
thought it would have been hilarious
last night if Donald Trump
would have come on Twitter now some some
were saying that he has some kind of
contract with true social about how
until June or some [__] but really he
owns what are they going to do the
contract isn't that he can't post so I
saw a lot of people were like oh no he
can't post a Twitter that's not true
that's not true it's an uh the deal is
that he can't post anywhere else first
if he's gonna post and he's gonna post
somewhere else he has to post a true
social first so you're saying like let's
say he constructs a a post he has to
post on true social then can post it on
Twitter yeah I don't know what the time
frame is but basically the way the
agreement works is that he has to post
on true social and then sometime after
it could be immediate or has maybe
there's a buffer but then it can go on
to other places so true social first and
then other places so Twitter or Facebook
because he posted Facebook getting
posted Twitter too so it's like that's
the that's the that's the um right well
that's the rule there and I think
Instagram he's posting on Instagram the
same way too yeah yeah and it could be
and the other and the other reason could
is like you know he doesn't post to
Twitter because he's got true social
kind of thing but yeah the agreement is
he posts to True social first and then
he posts to Instagram or right Facebook
well and here's the other thing I want
the audience to know because this this
is going to be the beginning of this
campaign between Ron DeSantis and Donald
Trump and this wasn't even this is
because he because then he went on to
Fox News and that was even worse oh and
way worse and and Rhonda santis is going
to stick this out through at least one
two or three primaries it's not gonna be
pretty and and let me tell you something
I'm excited about Donald Trump
destroying Ron desantis's political
career because Rhonda Santos and I've
said this time and time again that he
could have sat this out he could run in
2028 and he would have a damn good shot
of convincing people that he might be a
a reasonable nominee for the Republican
um party in 2028 he's not anymore he is
is going this is going to destroy any
chance he has of being dog catcher
elected dog catcher somewhere it is
going to absolutely destroy what is
going to happen is Rhonda Santos is
going to finish out his term as Governor
after he loses in one or two or three
primaries he loses all his all his big
money backers they're gonna walk away
from him he's not gonna have any money
you don't have money you can't run he's
gonna bow out and then what he'll do is
finish his term as Governor and then
he'll go sit on I don't know six eight
[__] corporate boards somewhere and
he'll be a corporatist he'll be a
corporatist like he's fighting he could
have you know honestly it's one of those
things where it's like man you should
have just finished out your term right
and then made a move right because
really he would have been finishing his
term and and and within six months of
finishing his his term as Governor he
could have announced for 2028. and he
probably could have had Donald Trump's
endorsement you know whatever the uh if
Donald Trump's alive well but he but but
he could have possibly captured Maga
right
this is good for democracy this fight
between these two is good for democracy
the fact that these you know two
fascists and others are thinking that
they're going to have any sort of chance
but in doing so they have to attack each
other it's like oh what did I expect the
[__] leopard ate my [__] face
right like you [__] racism great this
is you raised it and let it loose in the
room right right what not only that you
gave it leprosy you gave it lepers you
gave the lunatic leprosy intentional so
it would eat the faces of other people
like what the [__] did you expect so
here is the leopard The Lunatic eating
the face off of Ron DeSantis watch this
it's [__] crazy
[Music]
we are kind of melting the servers
okay I want to stop it there because you
just heard Elon say we're melting the
service that's real yeah this is
um for anyone yeah this is not like the
last one was made up Jake that was a big
one this one is actual video and audio
from Donald Trump his announcement and
then this is real audio from the Twitter
space yesterday this is real this is
[__] real this is from the first
Twitter space that they try to do right
here we go
government
[Music]
covered Santa's uh make this uh
[Applause]
um just trying to get it going
oh look man this is when when you're
when you're gonna make a big time
announcement like this like I don't know
the probably the biggest one of your
lifetime to say I'm gonna run for the
leader of the Free World the president
United States and I need to make a big
splash right
Elon Musk is not the first person that
comes to mind
if you look back at interviews
in conversations that Elon has
the you know obviously because he was
like oh he's you know he's autistic or
he's got uh you know he's on the
Spectrum or you know however different
people or however he describes himself
but he's not the person that you want to
have just based on other interviews
right based on other conversations he
has like he's not really the person that
you want to have leading a discussion
and leading one that is about hey
everyone I'm Rhonda santis and I'm
running for president right you want to
have someone that's like a big name
someone who's very charismatic very good
at speaking someone who can be like oh
[__] that's the name that is that's
someone who's gonna back him all right
I'll listen in right I'll listen in to
actually take it seriously versus I'll
listen in to laugh at the [__] show
that's gonna happen right and that's
what happened and David sax is no better
David sacks as you heard in the Echo
party he's like oh he just goes up
against the The Establishment
and I'm here with Ronda Ron the Santa
like what are we in a [__] a game
like somebody's about to uh and here
[Music]
ridiculous man and it's radio it's radio
now um I'll say that I actually believe
um that this
mocking this and especially the quote
mainstream media as they say let me pull
up Mario's tweet because I think this is
important
um because of the bitching about it
I'm like did he write this tweet or did
he saw him on right well aside well it
seems like Solomon but um aside aside
from a side from actual
um that launch and Rhonda Santos and
Elon talk
um because the Twitter spaces could be
valuable to creators right it could be
it's it's proven to be valuable for
creators but it it's trash so that the
problem is is when you start to build
this platform on top of a big heap of
trash it tends to do what happened last
night now some are saying and and it's
really the Elon and Twitter Sims that
are saying this [__] yeah um but Twitter
is under attack hypocrisy the mainstream
media now again we've been in Mario's
room and we actually invited Mario on
today
um to talk about this so
I'm not I'm not like just attacking
Mario here and didn't invite him on to
defend himself yeah because it's
possible that Mario didn't actually
write this tweet because other people
get into his account well whenever
there's a well here I'll say this it's
possible that he didn't write this tweet
and the reason I could believe that he
didn't write this tweet is because
there's a co-host he has called uh
people call him slay man or Salomon or
solomain or whatever anyway he's a guy
that's very like
anti-made stream it's always the big
corporate thing against you this and
that so there's a possibility he wrote
this tweet but there is this possibility
that Mario wrote it too right it's on
Mario's account it's on Mario's account
though yeah
um it it says three days ago Instagram
owned by meta experienced a worldwide
server outage but didn't face any
criticism for it and almost went
unnoticed again the what about ism is
incredible yeah and I'll explain the
huge difference between these two things
well I mean it's obvious obviously there
was this big huge presidential moment of
who's going to be the leader of the Free
World to announce on Twitter and with
the [__] owner of the platform on the
call on that guy the guy who said
Twitter right should be politically
neutral right which is different than
Instagram servers frying just happen
stance and it shuts down Instagram for
several hours but you know there's that
it goes on to say however when Elon Musk
made history by hosting Rhonda Santos on
Twitter spaces denounces run technical
issues arose and within minutes we
witnessed mainstream media articles
aggressively targeting Twitter yeah duh
because Elon is targeting [__]
mainstream ways that you receive content
so they're going to go on the attack
that's that but that is how hey I don't
know if you know this I don't know if
you know how capitalism and like and and
competition works but that's how it
works that's how it works and the
craziest part to me of course I know you
have one view of this but my view is a
little different but he goes on to give
several headlines here which go on to
attack Elon Musk and Twitter rightfully
so because it it was [__] hilarious
last night they should have had their
[__] together they should have known
what kind of load they were going to
have they should have expected this and
had it prepared and ready but they
didn't and that only speaks to Elon and
Twitter not exactly Twitter spaces
because it is garbage but they could
have done things to make sure that this
went off without a hitch and they didn't
and it says this clearly demonstrates
the media's apprehension towards Twitter
as citizen journalism gains prominence
uh while they decline which is totally
that's total [__] that's total
[__] I I hate how people they
separate media from citizen journalism
listen citizen journalism is not media
it can be we're media we're not [__]
journalism we're media we're talking
into microphones we got the cameras and
lights on it's broadcasting that's
[__] media yeah this idea this idea
that you get to [__] hack it up how
you want to serve your interests as dumb
as dog [__] right um goes on to say
despite and here's the what about isn't
more again despite Instagram's worldwide
server outage Jesus Christ facing little
to no negative coverage which is
[__] it was trending on Twitter
[__] the moment a single Twitter
space crashes multiple hit pieces were
swiftly released by many media Outlets
because it's about politics it wasn't
just about [__] Instagram servers
going down also like if I were to look
this up right now on Google I just go
Instagram outage guess what I find
Reuters Instagram
nope Gabe Sanchez there's no articles
that's fake news don't say it because
it's fake news Instagram suffers
worldwide outage Global outage wakes
meme Fest whoa you mean you mean
Instagram Instagram dude we got local we
got variety we got Daily Mail we got the
Verge you mean mainstream media rare
Economic Times oh my God it's almost
like they didn't put those headlines in
this tweet okay so the finals the hill
the final sentence here in in this tweet
um is is in bold and it says citizen
journalism is perceived as a threat by
the media and this is exactly why we
must fight to defend it I'm not a I'm
not disagreeing that we should defend
independent journalism they keep calling
it citizen journalism it's independent
journalism just I I I hate I hate how
they [__] they've got a fashion
everything citizen journaling well
that's Elon he's like oh the man citizen
journalists anyone any you don't have to
God damn it you don't oh gee okay the
best way to describe this is um
well I guess the only way to describe it
is uh stop being [__] dumb but
um by adding citizen like you don't have
to be you're a journalist you're a
journalist you're a journalist you
notice your corporate you're independent
you're you're a citizen it doesn't
matter journalist when I talk to people
on the phone I don't say I'm a citizen
journalist I say I'm a journalist or I'm
a reporter doing the story I would like
to get a quote right and then I do that
for my segment what was that but when I
talk to someone I don't say I'm a
citizen journalist and they're like I'm
a threat are you one of those [__]
fascists no I say I'm a journalist and
I'd like to call for comment right and
then they say oh no comments whatever
okay yeah whatever oh that's a lie and
I'll give you proof that it's a non-line
lie like George Santos does but here's
the thing here's the thing here's the
thing because I I I'd love to do the
what about ISM with Instagram and that's
the most ridiculous argument that anyone
could make that no one reported about
the Instagram adage again the minute it
happened everyone moved over to Twitter
and it's like what the [__] is going on
on Instagram and whenever it happens
correctly whatever happened it's always
somebody that's like is it just me I
mean there's literal websites that says
is it down or is it just me right and
you type in and you see what and they're
like oh actually there's reported
outages here right whether it's Facebook
Instagram Tick Tock or when Twitter goes
down yeah and I and again like I you go
to Google and or you go to [__] go
[__] DuckDuckGo or whatever the [__]
you use and you type in Instagram outage
and even three days ago four days ago
all of this stuff worldwide outage
multiple Publications
domestic International Tech news
entertainment right across the board
everything every major news Outlet
where's the reporter heard of but they
weren't reporting but they weren't
reporting on it
uh they weren't reporting that a
presidential candidate failed to launch
and it melted the server because it
didn't because they because Mark
Zuckerberg didn't have someone hosting
on to announce their presidential
campaign also that's not something Mark
Zuckerberg did the thing that I that I
don't like is the fact that he's like oh
we're melting the surface no you're not
no you're not what you're doing is
you're overloading the servers now the
police have enough space and and the
idea and there's a re oh God okay
this also annoys me for someone who's
like I'm a [__] genius I'm a rocket
scientist the phrase melt the servers
isn't happening because servers are in a
temperature controlled environment okay
there's a reason why people are like oh
we want to build [__] a server Farm
in Antarctica because it's cheap because
it's cold I don't have to spend extra
money to keep the surface cool so they
don't overheat right
the the oh we're melting the surface
that won't imply that you're [__]
melting the drives
and that has to be so [__] hot so
[__] hot for that to happen Okay
melting metal okay yes it is Kelly on
Twitch says it's rocket surgery so the
idea that he's like oh man we're melting
it we're melting the servers no what did
someone go in there with a [__]
flamethrower like a SpaceX flamethrower
[__] melted she just wouldn't have
enough snow
what happened right so so here's what
I'll say here's what I'll say uh and
then I want to move to the Marjorie
Taylor green because I gotta show that
clip I gotta show the Marjorie Tankard
it's great it's [__] great because we
all like the Laugh here yeah we all like
to laugh at merger Taylor green and it's
the perfect clip for that so
my take on it is this is that listen the
reason why the mainstream media is going
to rail Twitter is because Twitter last
night clearly has not figured out the
concept of radio and literally that is
what it is it is Radio I don't give a
[__] you can talk to me all you want
there's no other feature than audio in
this thing that's it I mean yeah you can
post something in the nest but that's
Twitter you're on [__] Twitter so you
can so you can tag a Twitter a tweet to
the [__] radio show that's it that's
all it's just radio it's just radio and
the other thing that it is is just
mobile because yesterday you sent me a
screenshot of the desktop totally
crashing in the very [__] beginning
before they even got started before they
couldn't even it could not even pull up
any sort of metadata like the title the
owner anything he said it could not be
found you would believe that the desktop
version would be much more stable in the
mobile version but it's not and the
reason why it's because the the entire
[__] Foundation of Twitter spaces was
built for the mobile app that's it
that's what it was built for that's why
if Elon Musk wants Twitter spaces to to
be something good which I believe it can
be I actually think that it can be I
think that if he abandoned Periscope
abandoned what is Twitter spaces and
create something new that is called
Twitter spaces that has audio and video
uh the Creator and the people in the
room can engage with the audience in
real time I believe that that is
something that could work in Twitter but
it would take months and years to build
something like that but they're not
they're not abandoning anything they're
just building another big heap of
garbage on top of a flaming heap of
[__] garbage and then it's radio it's
just radio that's why the mainstream
media is going to drag you because they
figured out radio 100 [__] years ago
[__] there's the radio there's a reason
why I you know I mean the the most the
most advancement we've had to radio is
using satellites to broadcast
overseas you mean like at just making it
uh to where the audio instead of over
Airwaves or over the Internet is that
what you're saying oh my God it's not it
sounds really complicated it sounds
really complicated but the fact that
Elon Musk wants to claim this I'm a
genius and all this [__] and I'm
melting I'm melting the servers at the
data center no that's not happening and
if that is and and mind you if that is
actually if he's [__] melting the the
servers at the data center
then there's a much bigger problem going
on using Amazon servers no not at all
because Amazon like AWS like Amazon's
using Amazon servers and if it and if he
is I mean it would be very expensive uh
to do that but also
if he was doing that then he could have
done that last night during that time I
mean you would have to it's not as easy
as you think I mean you'd have to be
porting over well I mean you might have
to have I don't know a couple Engineers
to help you do right but if you are it's
one of those things like if you're a
company that has that much data that's
being transferred and you own then you
want to own it yourself you don't want
to have it to someone else because you
want to so you're saying you're saying
that you're you're saying that Twitter
controls their theirs yeah it's the same
thing as like if you if you like
Facebook Facebook has data centers all
over the world right because it also
deals with like how close the connection
is to where you are in terms of how I
relay data from one point to another
right so if I'm always wait you're
acting like the internet goes through
wires sometimes man it's crazy dude
I'm just saying Cat5 cables right you
act like you act like the internet goes
through cables and [__] yeah I don't
know man it's wild we're still we're
still in that but but the last thing
I'll say about it is is if you're
Twitter you have your own data centers
because again you have 238 million daily
active users on your platform 80 million
daily active users the biggest
proportion of them are in the US so you
have multiple data centers around the US
you have data centers internationally
you have data centers in various
different countries because you have to
make sure that you can maintain that
type of traffic and sustain it without
apps crashing but if you don't have the
engineering you don't have the resources
you fired the people that were once in
charge of it that know how these things
work then that's on you but also if
you're in fact melting the servers at
the data center
then that says a lot about how you're
actually running operations come on man
they are maintaining the environment in
which you're holding those servers do
you got a couple extra minutes because I
ain't sure okay all right speaking of
melting down and melting live watch this
this is Trey Gowdy I don't know if you
know who Trey County he's a Benghazi
I believe is the Dollar Store Anderson
Cooper look at this guy
this guy's looking worse and worse every
day he he had meatball on and he asked
him uh you know you ask him a question
now you gotta remember Trey Gowdy is a
former politician turn Fox News host
politician well you know whatever
he's he's won around desantis's former
colleagues in the house to be quite
honest and uh he was the one who botched
the Benghazi he couldn't get Hillary
Clinton on [__] right yeah but he's
asking Ronda Santos what I think would
be an actual legitimate question for a
president's candidate it's it's a
softball to be quite honest to a me it's
a softball team it's a meatball it's a
it's a meatball it's it's they're
tossing a meatball right tossing a
meatball here but it is a question that
you would ask someone who you think
would might get the nomination for
president listen to how Ron DeSantis
replies to this question let's listen to
the question first all right you uh wore
the uniform if you are elected president
you may be the first one in a while uh
to have worn the uniform how would you
address the ongoing war in Eastern
Europe between Russia and Ukraine on day
one of Iran DeSantis presidency okay
that sounds like I mean I mean it's kind
of again it's a softball question you
know he's not really pointing in or
aiming at anything and let's also
remember what Rhonda Santos did he was
the assistant to the urinalysis
specialist okay that's what he did and
when he was in Guantanamo he was the one
you mean he put the lid on the p cup and
put the label on and filled out he had
to he had to get it because there's like
the urinalysis like coordinator right
and they're they're like all right great
we've got you know uh military member
number one they come in and they go
follow your information we got you Ron
DeSantis has to then go in and take the
Piston Cup and then take a cap and screw
it on and wipe it down so the actual
urinalysis coordinator doesn't have to
touch [__] maybe that's why he eats
pudding with his fingers I mean maybe it
reminds him that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying anyways Okay
let's listen let's listen to putting
meatballs answer here you would think it
had to do with like I don't know like um
you know the Ukraine Russia first day
being president nope totally goes for
the genitalia watch this
well first I think what we need to do as
a veteran is recognize that our military
has become politicized you talk about
gender ideology you talk about things
like global warming that they're somehow
concerned and that's not the military
that I served in we need to return our
military uh to focusing on uh committing
and focusing on the core values and the
core mission that would be something
that I could take care of on day one
very good and Trey gout he's like what
the [__] did you say what are we talking
about now did you just did you just say
genitalia is the first thing you're
going to be concerned not only that but
it's like if there was actually
something that we should do with the
military I don't know I'm gonna go on a
limb here and if I'm going to talk about
something that's unrelated to the
military because he's like all these uh
they're getting woke and they're getting
a little Thug and gender no the thing
that we should focus on with the
military and the thing that we should
put in for for actual effort on day one
is supporting the veterans of our
military as someone who is supposed to
be from the [__] military okay even
though he was a urinalysis coordinator
assistant or assistant to the urinalysis
coordinator and was there watching and
overseeing the the
um torture at Guantanamo Bay by
force-feeding detainees which is which
is told in in admitted to it in 2018.
well and the people he [__] tortured
said yeah it was him I saw him he was
standing there and that's the reason why
he got so flustered in uh in Jerusalem
when somebody asked me how would they
how
the person that's laughing and
if that trauma would remember
but if I was Ron you know [__] I
don't want to imagine that if I'm Rhonda
Sanders If I Was President and I was
someone from the military and had that
military background and I came in day
one my first start of business to to
actually have something would be like oh
well how do we actually support the
military once they're out no no no
actually now now you're like hey what do
you got in your pants buddy what do you
got in your pants what is that in your
britches and maybe that's why he's so
focused on genitalia because he's so
because he's so used to watching could
be it sticks God damn that's it so
DeSantis war room is a Twitter account
and I'm gonna show you what they
officially say if I can get the [__]
thing to come up here
um it's what the f what the [__] man it
says rapid the rapid response for Aunt
Rhonda Santos okay so this is a video
that they put out and the Tweet says
Governor Ron DeSantis rank for president
to lead our Great American comeback
that's one thing and he kept saying
that's his that's his campaign slogan
Great American comeback I I saw this
video yeah and my
good uh
good uh whenever okay I saw this video
this morning and my only feedback was is
Elon Musk
well so I'm gonna mute it here so here's
Ron you see Ron coming on stage uh wait
that's not Rhonda said that's not Elon
Musk oh there's Ron DeSantis he's run
president wait that's Elon Musk hey
there's Ron there's Ron wait that's Elon
Musk what the [__] are they the same
[__]
that's how we Mount those servers
wait that's Ron no that's not Ron that's
that's Ron wait
that that's not Ron there's Ron when he
was Ron there's one yep that's not right
that's Elon Musk that's this is weird as
[__] that's Elon why listen
I'm just gonna go out on a limb here and
I don't like conspiracy theories I'm
just asking questions I'm just asking
questions
is is the fascist alien
wearing two different skin suits one in
the morning is Rhonda Santos and one at
night as Elon Musk is it the same
fascist little alien that is wearing
these humanoids let's think of this
right yeah
um I've never seen them in the same room
together that is true they were in an
audio Twitter space but that could be
done with meatball Ai No No I know
totally like you you never heard them
speak at the same time you know they
could change their you know they could
change the way that they speak if
there's an alien inside like Men In
Black he could change how he speaks I
totally agree but I I think also
that this what I don't see I even I
forgot all I remember was gak I don't
even know what the what the [__] I I
just don't remember what the phrase was
I just remember it's gak and when I
think gack my only question to people is
are they gonna have cats are they gonna
have Gat cats is it gonna be Manga
versus Geck yeah
every single [__] time okay let me
show you one more thing and then we'll
go to the Marjorie Taylor green and then
we're gonna have to let the audience go
because we're running out of time or
we're already out of time we're overtime
this is Ben Shapiro's little here here's
his this Brainiac here's him giving his
thoughts on what happened last night he
says that 2024 Republican primary is a
contrast to be sure DeSantis will attack
Trump on substance Trump will attack
DeSantis on personnel Ali that's already
fully obvious we'll see which one
Republican voters care about you dumb
[__] this guy every day [__]
attacks people for what they wear how
they look how fat they are every day on
his [__] show and on his Network and
you're what and he's wondering what his
viewers the Republican primary voters
are gonna which one they're gonna pick
yeah well you know which one they're
gonna pick because you cater to them
every [__] day you piece of Nazi
sludge you want to know here's a good
example of the leopardy in your face
this is the guy who would not say Trump
directly by name after he had dinner
with Kanye West and Nick Fuentes both
known Nazi lovers and Hitler lovers
they've said it white supremacist they
love Hitler
he would not say directly
that Donald Trump had dinner or should
not have had dinner with these two
people right what he said is oh if you
don't want to be attacked for having
dinner with the white supremacist or
Neo-Nazi or whatever then don't have
dinner with the white supremacist
Neo-Nazi well also
you should call them out by name right
but then he got upset that everyone was
attacking him he's like oh man all you
guys are right white supremacist or you
guys are anti-semitic and it's like what
do you think man you you built these
people up man right you fed into it and
now like you fed the leopard and you're
like it's not gonna eat my face oh it's
definitely gonna hit your face it's
definitely gonna eat your face speaking
of people who get their faces eaten off
this is a video of Marjorie Taylor green
um she was she was gambling over the
house yes she was it she was in charge
yesterday and she thought she would she
would ask for it and I use in I want to
say in charge with big [__] air
quests in charge Marge baby junior to
the max air quotes right listen to this
now this is this may or may not be
edited with a little bit of a sound in
there but let's listen
[Music]
the members are reminded to abide by
decorum of the house
it's not a laugh track you hear that is
Democrats real audio that music is added
but the Laughing is real laughing at her
about her what are you going for decorum
what do you think is funnier
or what do you think had more laughter
This Moment Like collectively this
moment
or Ron DeSantis on Twitter spaces
totally Ron DeSantis way more land
you couldn't hear it because it wasn't
in one room dude I was busting up
laughing I could I had to go outside so
I wouldn't disturb the people inside I
was laughing so [__] hard but let's
listen to this laughter inside
[Applause]
she can't get them to cooperate
the house will be in order
good try though Mark yeah you're the
same woman who who got up on two
separate occasions during the state of
the union and said
you liar
right don't even come back out of here
with this idea that oh we should be into
Quorum the lady
that's [__] pot calling the kettle
black man right no [__] no [__]
and I wouldn't [__] you you're my
favorite turds and because you're my
favorite turds I'm gonna haven't asked
me anything on patreon here in just a
little bit so I gotta do my edits we're
gonna have Joe flood on tomorrow I'm
gonna do an audio video test with him if
you wanna if you wanna do that with me
you can uh earned an audio video test so
we make sure that tomorrow when he joins
the broadcast he's good to go uh and
then I'll do an ask me anything so if
you're on patreon uh go to patreon.com
the Tony Michaels you'll see the link
there when I get it posted when I'm
ready to do and ask me anything we'll do
it for 30 minutes I'll probably do it at
like a top of the hour bottom of the
hour right to make it you know work
correct but we'll do it for 30 minutes
if you're not on patreon go over right
now and go to patreon.com and and check
that out if you want to be a part of the
ask me anything I know you got some
stuff going on so while you're on
patreon.com go over to Gabe's page I am
Gabe Sanchez almost at 100. I'm like 90
94. yeah so go over and give gave some
support you can go to what was
thatshow.com it'll take you directly to
his patreon or or you go to patreon.com
I am Gabe Sanchez check out what he's
got going over there also make sure you
subscribe here on YouTube it's free to
subscribe here on YouTube don't forget
you'll be able to vote on YouTube on the
community tab tonight for bonehead of
the week you vote you decide to his
phone in the week we break it down for
you tomorrow you can also vote on elon's
Twitter as long as the servers aren't
melting at Tony Michael's pod you can
vote there tonight and if you want to
watch tomorrow's episode with bonehead
of the week you can watch it on Facebook
that is if the servers aren't melting
over there and the media is not
reporting on it just go to at Tony
Michaels at the Tony Michaels on
Facebook you can watch every single
episode there also I want to thank
everyone on Twitch we got several new
subscribers today and a bunch of new
followers it's free to follow us on
Twitch it does take a little bit to
subscribe to us on Twitch here's a free
way to do it if you have an Amazon Prime
account you can link your Prime account
to your Twitch account right and then
you use your one free subscription they
give you with your Amazon Prime account
you can use that to give to us every
single month you got to renew it every
single month it's a little work when
they give us free money you know you
gotta do a little work but it's free for
you if you're an Amazon Prime user to
give us that one free subscription just
link your Amazon Prime account to your
Twitch account you go to the Tony
michaels.com the instructions are like
the fourth link down it says link Amazon
and twitch it'll give you the
instructions on how to do that there I
want to I want to tell you guys
um I will be here Memorial Day I I don't
know if Gabe has plans or not but I will
be here Memorial day uh I believe so um
but I want you to have a safe weekend
we're not quite there yet but uh if
you're if you're off tomorrow and you're
out traveling because tomorrow is Friday
a lot of people will will won't be able
to watch tomorrow because they're be
doing stuff with their Fame I completely
understand I want you guys to have a
safe weekend also I want to welcome all
the sparklers that are here but you
always got a lot of sparklers in the
space now we welcome Hal's fans here at
the Tony Michaels podcast so I want to
tell you that and and tomorrow we'll do
bone and the week and we also are going
to have Joe flood the guy that was on
the red bike mocking the Patriot front
there live in DC so we're gonna ask him
about that uh tomorrow I'm super excited
about having him on the show and I'm
super excited that you guys are going to
have fun and great Memorial Day weekend
I know we went over time today but again
again go to patreon.com D Tony Michaels
I'll be doing ask me anything while
you're over there check out Gabe's page
shoes he's almost a 200 no I'm also that
100 100 okay 200 I wish I'm a little oh
I'm a 220 or 221 I think
um you're almost you're almost at 100.
so go over give give some support on our
patreon if you can check out my page
we're gonna do an ask me anything
probably within the next hour is when
we'll do ask me anything here's how ask
me anything works just before we leave
you'll be able to come in we'll be there
for 30 minutes you'll be able to ask me
anything in the chat and for 30 minutes
I will answer questions no matter how
difficult they need to answer and I'm
sure you're going to ask about how many
Margaritas I had last night they were
asking me that earlier but how many
margaritas
one two three four
three funny the Peggy [__] I want the
Peggy oh my God everyone be safe uh have
a great Memorial Day weekend if you
can't watch us tomorrow we'll be here
tomorrow I'll be here on Monday I think
Gabe will be too if not
um um we'll we'll work through this but
you have a great Memorial Day weekend if
you can't see us tomorrow but otherwise
same time
same place tomorrow five Margaritas
[__] Surf's Up [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon